-Our first guest tonight
is one of my favorites.
You'll be able to see him soon
in the movie "North Hollywood."
Please welcome Vince Vaughn,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's -- That's what I'm --
That's what
I'm talking about, here.
Vince!
-Good to see you, man.
-It is always --
-Congrats on being
back in the studio.
-Oh, thank you, buddy.
Yeah, we got an audience.
It's unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's amazing.
Like seeing a terrific dolphin
released back into the ocean.
It's nice to see.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly
how I'd describe it, yeah.
You were with us
when we did our shows at home
and then in the other studio
and now back in our original
"Tonight Show" with an audience,
so I appreciate you
being a friend of the show.
Thank you for
helping us out, buddy.
-Yeah, great to be with you.
Are you glad to be back?
-It's amazing.
I mean, to be honest,
the first show we came back,
I was a little bit too emotional
just coming out,
'cause I was like --
I wasn't ready for it.
I'm like, "Whew,
I need to tell jokes."
[ Laughs ]
But now it's the greatest.
It feels like we're slowly
getting back to normal,
you know, so it feels good.
-Yeah, for sure. And it's nice
to have a feeling about it
that you like, and I think
that's a good thing.
-Yeah. Yeah, thanks. Yeah.
I was going to ask you, did you
watch the Derby this weekend?
Kentucky Derby?
-You know, I usually always
watch the Derby.
I never miss it.
But this year because of kids'
sports, I did miss the Derby.
But I saw that Bob Baffert,
who's a great trainer,
that he had kind of a long shot
that won.
-Yeah, it was unbelievable.
Yeah, I know -- What, do you
have to take the kids --
Are they playing baseball
or something?
-Yeah. There was a baseball game
and a soccer game,
and there was
traveling involved.
We've talked about this.
For some reason,
you have to drive 35 minutes
to play other 9-year-olds.
It's a confusing process.
[ Laughter ]
I don't understand.
I don't understand it,
but I'm on the train.
It's not stopping,
but I don't understand.
-And of course, they're playing
probably two different fields
and different times
and all that stuff?
-And then you can't find --
I don't know
which field is what.
There's a field behind the field
and you didn't know about that.
And people are in tears,
and you're late, and it's --
You know what I mean?
It's all complicated.
But I'm glad we're playing.
I'm grateful the kids
are back playing sports.
So, no complaints.
Now, did you enjoy the Derby?
Was that an exciting --
What happened that made this
memorable for you?
-I enjoyed it. I love -- I do --
For me, watching horse racing,
it reminds me of my childhood,
'cause that was like a treat
for us to go to like a smoky OTB
with a bunch of alcoholics,
and you just let the kids
run free, and, yeah.
And Grandpa took me there, just
bet on horses and just gambled,
bunch of people gambling,
smoking cigarettes, and, yeah.
-I had the same childhood.
It was Arlington Park
in Chicago.
And my dad would always take me,
and there were a group of kids
that would play tag
near the finish line.
My dad would let me pick horses.
So there would be --
He would give me $2 a race.
And whatever we won,
we would split, if I won.
And if I lost, we were even,
so I couldn't complain
about the setup.
But, you know, you just
pick the horses by name,
and every now and then,
you'd hit a long shot.
It felt like a nice day.
-I don't know if I ever told you
about my worst investment ever.
Did I ever tell you about this?
-[ Laughs ] No. Please.
-So, this is
not that far long ago.
But anyways, I was
on "Saturday Night Live,"
and this was the first time I
was actually making real money.
And some guy
in my building said,
"Hey, Jimmy, do you want to
invest in a race horse?"
And I go, "Yes. Of course."
And so he's like, "Alright,
I'll get you details later."
And I go, "Oh, my God."
I called my dad and my mom.
I go, "I'm going to invest
in a race horse!
I'm going to own a horse."
It's going to be fantastic.
And it was
a lot of money for me.
And I called
my business manager.
He said, "Do not do this.
This is a disaster.
This a waste of money.
Don't even do this."
I go, "No, I got to do it.
I was raised -- I have to."
So I go, I'm going to go
to the stables every day.
I'm going to comb it.
I'm going to brush its teeth.
I don't care. I'm going to say,
"You are Sea Warrior,
and you're going to win
the Kentucky Derby."
And so, I called my friend
after I made the investment.
And he goes --
I go, "When do you name it?
He goes, "What do you mean?
It's already named.
You don't name the horse.
It's named by like the sire
of the," you know --
I go, "Oh, what's the name
of our horse?"
He goes, "It's Poco Bueno."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-I go, "Poco Bueno?"
I go, "What does that mean?"
He goes, "It means
a little bit good."
-Little bit good.
-I go, "Who --
Why didn't we get Mucho Bueno?
I mean, I would have been happy
with Bueno,
regular Bueno."
I got Poco Bueno.
And I went to OTB
to see his debut,
and I put some money on him
with my friend.
And he came in last place,
and I haven't seen him since.
-Did you put him
in a claiming race,
or was it -- Did it get claimed?
-Yeah. It was in
a real, actual race.
It was in the gate. I know that.
-See, you just picture
like winning things
and in the circle and crying
and dreams coming true.
But the reality is,
someone's got to feed the horse,
and the horse has to be washed,
and there's a lot of expenses
before Little Good -- Little Bit
Good gets a chance to race.
Little Bit Good
needs lots of food.
-Yeah. Yeah.
What I heard, right now,
he's an Uber driver.
And that's what I heard.
That's what he does now.
-But he's happy, Jimmy.
He's happy. He's happy.
-Yeah, he doesn't
like racing anymore.
It's not his thing, you know?
You have a movie coming out,
"North Hollywood."
-Yes.
-This is -- Who -- Mikey Alfred.
-Mikey Alfred.
Yeah, I did this movie.
I like this young filmmaker.
He's a young kid,
and he comes from
the skateboard culture,
and he had like
a coming of age movie,
and I was just
really impressed with him.
So I said
that I would do the movie.
So, I'm glad that I did it.
It's a nice, little movie
that he made.
He's a first-time director.
And it's, like, this whole
skateboarding culture
that was very interesting.
-Is it about his life?
-It is. It's sort of
based on his life, yes.
It's sort of based on his, kind
of, growing up skateboarding
and making a decision
to pursue that.
-Vince, I wanted to ask you --
You act in a lot of movies.
You produce movies.
And I was wondering
if you would play a game with me
that is about --
-Yes, I'll play a game
as long as it doesn't involve
investing in horses
or things of that nature.
-We'll talk about that
over the commercial break.
We'll discuss.
-Okay.
-Alright. Good.
More with Vince Vaughn.